yeah how did that initial like
connection happen because i do like look
kanye keeps you know he got pushed
around and he got sigh high around and
we got some of the greatest lyricists of
all time around
but like you specifically how did that
relationship start did he reach out his
people reach out
it was i i i really don't know if it was
like
he reached out or whatever but i just
remember
this was on that sunday after our show
at the noble
last show with a tour which was right
before everything shut down right before
march
shut down that's really march 7th yep
march 8th we went to sunday service that
morning i remember that
yeah i remember and he
seen us in a crowd look like oh you know
what man
so after this joint you know what i mean
bring us in the back of this [ __ ] or
whatever
and we just sit in there and kanye he's
a real sporadic like
you know you know dude like that like
he's just like you know
man we need to go to cabo and just
record all this energy right now i
looked in the crowd i seen y'all there
you know i mean like we just need to all
just get on the jet just go to cobble
you know i mean me and benny looking at
each other like [ __ ] [ __ ] ain't we
we got warrants one all right yeah
yeah i mean so we ended up going we
literally ended up going to wyoming the
next morning
so the next morning so tour ends soar
ends next morning we go to sunday
service
next morning we fly into wyoming
wow
was gunn not there yeah he came um
like cause i remember he he he had like
a meeting with with with guys
yeah he had some other [ __ ] guys but me
and benny was already out there yo
wow so let me ask you this like you're
all over some
first of all obviously you helping him
with
with with creating records but is there
going to be any sort of
i don't know if is there is there any
kanye records where you
or benny are on the record with him that
exists
not saying they're ever going to come
out
oh man i mean you went to wyoming
there is one there's there's a record
benny's not on it but i was in the room
i'm with the [ __ ] you feel me and he
like yeah
like i want to just keep your verse on
there
and have wes still want it then i'll do
the third verse type [ __ ]
yo it's wild because like you know [ __ ]
that wyoming
thing is real like you know push came
out of the other side of wyoming with
daytona
yeah was there something about being in
the middle of nowhere like that that was
inspiring your creative
process because you know that [ __ ] is in
the middle of nowhere
you like jackson hole or wherever it is
man cause it's so peace and tranquil
right so peaceful and tranquil man that
you just ain't got no time
to do nothing but kind of your mind is
kind of opened up you know what i'm
saying
so yeah man it's inspiring especially
just to be
you know you know initially it's just
you got to get over the nerves or like
you know it's kanye right here
like you know what i'm saying like he we
in the same you know
baby like you kanye west yeah i mean we
sitting here like that
so you know i still look at like i'm an
up-and-coming [ __ ] in the game so it's
moments like that i'll be
on my like oh man you've had a few of
those first day
was kind of like i i was kind of like i
had a bad
game if we talk of sports terms okay but
the next day i did like maybe like two
or three songs
then the next day like the more
comfortable i got the more you know what
i'm saying because it's like
it's it's different atmosphere than the
type of studio atmosphere that you're
used to
you know right like there's no cussing
ain't nobody caught saying ain't no
smoking no drinking or none of that
this world just it's good energy though
it's it's great energy like
were you on your jesus [ __ ] when you was
rapping yeah okay yeah yeah
so he took you to a different place
cause i'm like yo you you on that
you're talking that talk you know what
i'm
you know what i'm saying i kind of just
i found a way to kind of just make it
like to where i was just thankful
for even having a second chance at life
and to be in this position
because i you know [ __ ] like i said i
could have been left i could have died
when i got shot so
i just you know talked about
those times where like you know i feel
like god
was there for me i mean you guys have
had
m with obviously you guys did the shady
situation yeah yeah
hov now yay uh i'll be damned if
the buffalo boys ain't ain't on to
something right right yeah this [ __ ] is
crazy